jump into this first story we have this
from Fox News witness to Jordan nearly
Chokehold death calls Daniel penny a
hero NYC passenger says Marine vet cared
for people and that is his crime the
funny thing is that's literally a crime
these days caring for others in New York
City especially they say a retiree who
witnessed the Fatal choking incident
call Daniel penny a hero and slammed
Manhattan D.A Alvin Bragg for
prosecuting him he's a Heroes of the
passenger the witness who described
herself as a woman of color said it was
wrong for Bragg to charge Penny it was
self-defense and I believe in my heart
that he saved a lot of people that day
that could have gotten hurt you know I
want to I want to point point out too
when we look at this video and we hear
the story of uh of Jordan Neely
threatening to hurt people I I don't
know about you guys but I kind of feel
like I'm probably underestimating how
serious it was like it's not just some
guy threatening people I'm willing to
bet it's more serious than anybody
believes like he was getting up in
someone's face or coming at somebody or
or doing like a Flinch you know it's
like take like a like a faint shot at
him to try and get him you know
something is more than just him yelling
well yeah I mean because people on the
subway are thanking him there's footage
of people thinking him after it occurred
I haven't seen anything about anyone who
is on that train car coming out and
saying he went too far and shouldn't
have done this I've heard nothing at all
about nothing from anyone that was on
the training are actually complaining
nobody has said anything negative and
I'm a hero yeah I mean I can't imagine
why there would be protesters saying
that the people that were on the train
that didn't stop
the Marine I forget his name the Marine
from from Penny Penny from from
restraining Jordan like they're asking
they're they're saying that the other
people should be punished for not doing
what they're literally punishing penny
for right now well this is hilarious
right because here's what would happen
if they could go back in time if they
had a time machine they go back in time
and then they stop him from putting the
assailants in a Chokehold and then
everyone gets charged for not stopping
them from putting him in a choke holds
and putting him in a Chokehold and then
he has just a chain of everyone putting
them in a Chokehold and never going into
jail for putting him in each other New
York is finished Colby have you have you
seen the video about what happened with
this Marine I haven't seen the video but
I've I've heard uh some of the reports
about it and you know it's disgusting it
you know Daniel penny is a hero he's a
good Samaritan obviously everybody on
the train felt threatened by by that
Jordan Neely so I mean look at Jordan
Neely's pass I mean isn't he didn't he
like rape a kid or like kidnap something
yeah
he was arrested several times he punched
an old man man and an old woman in the
face in different occasions he was
arrested like was it like 40 times or
something but I'm curious I I guess I'm
trying to ask you because I think out of
anybody in the room you're the only one
who has any expertise in fighting yeah
and I'm wondering I don't know like is
there concern
for for you knowing how to actually
fight I guess the argument we've heard
from the left is
it what Jordan nearly did didn't warrant
choking him to death and my response was
I don't think Penny was trying to choke
him to death I think he was trying to
stop him so I guess I don't know enough
about fighting to know where that line
is or what what you think about what is
acceptable in terms of subduing somebody
yeah you know he was obviously trying to
subdue him and there's no way anybody
could have thought he was gonna kill him
by just you know removing his conscious
you know by choking him out it happens
in the UFC all the time guys get rid of
naked choke they go to sleep and then
they wake up so there must be some type
of cause in in the Jordan Neely that
caused that death you know I don't think
it was just by natural causes from a
Choco I think there's some
extracurricular activity going on maybe
he was doing drugs maybe some other
things that's actually what a lot of
people think yeah because he he
afterwards uh Penny puts him in the
recovery position and the other
passengers and then he was still moving
and breathing and then they bring him to
the hospital and he died I guess it was
like on the way there or something yeah
well I mean regardless this guy was
acting in defense of the other people on
the train he didn't he didn't just go
out of his way to choke this dude out
for no reason yeah I mean look no matter
what how people wanted to spin the
interaction the like Jordan was being
restrained like Perry wasn't
aggressively attacking him that's not
what anyone saw they looked at the if
you look at the video Jordan they were
trying to restrain Jordan trying to hold
his hands trying to prevent him from
hurting someone else they weren't on him
smashing his head exactly they were
beating him that wasn't an aggressive
fight that was trying to prevent him
from being aggressive against other
people you obviously you know what it
looks like when someone's aggressively
trying to punch someone you know it
doesn't look like he was trying to hurt
him that's what I'm saying this guy was
a marine if he wanted to just savagely
beat this guy to death it would have
looked very different it would have
looked very different check this out so
the witness the witness account from
this woman she's in her 60s she said I'm
sitting on the train reading my book and
all of a sudden I hear someone spewing
this rhetoric he said I don't care if I
have to kill an F I will I will I will
go to jail I'll take a bullet recall the
woman who's in her 60s the terrified
passengers crowded towards the exit
doors I'm looking at where we are in the
tube in the Sardine Can and I'm like
okay we're between stations there's
nowhere we can go the people on the
train we were scared we were scared for
our lives panties stepped in when nearly
studies in the world kill and bullet why
in the world would you take a bullet why
you don't take a bullet because you
snatched something from somebody's hand
you take it for violence the witness
said it was clear to her that Penny wait
until the last minute to intervene for
the sake of his fellow passengers shared
a thump when he dragged nearly to the
ground but couldn't clearly see until
the doors opened at the Broadway
Lafayette station and most of the
passengers exited the witness waited for
police to arrive to provide a statement
Mr Penny cared for people that's what he
did that is his crime she told Fox News
digital after the altercation she and at
least three other passengers thanked him
damn that's amazing nobody wants to kill
anybody Mr Penny didn't want to kill
that man you should have seen the way Mr
Penny looked he was distraught he was
very very visibly distressed and he
didn't go he didn't run he stayed
prosecutor Joshua steinglass said at
Penny's arraignment Friday that the
Marine veteran who has lived his entire
life in the New York area continued to
hold nearly for a period of time after
the man had stopped moving I don't think
that's true I think in the video you can
see the dude is still waving his arms
around and there's other men trying to
stop him so something else was going on
than just this
they took three men to hold Mr Neely
down he was struggling after widespread
protester across the city with many
demonstrators even politicians calling
penny a murderer brag charged Penny and
now I'm hearing that they're they're
like regular New Yorkers saying
criminal charges should not be coming
from a tiny Fringe group of people
that's something I mean I obviously we
can't verify whether or not the people
that have been protesting are actually
New Yorkers or not but it wouldn't
surprise me considering the history of
protests you know the past five or so
years in the U.S that these people were
from out of state making a stink in a in
the subway when your average New Yorker
is probably like please don't charge
this guy because we all hate dealing
with mentally unstable people on in the
Subway because they are there are
mentally unstable people they they do
need help the the city needs to do
something about it but at the end of the
day it's the average New Yorker that
pays the price you know it's like
they're the ones that that get
terrorized when they're on the subway
and stuff so I just know I don't see how
the average person in New York City is
like oh you know we need to punish this
guy there's more uh the guy who filmed
it said he started screaming he said he
had no food no drink that he was tired
doesn't care if he goes to jail he
started screaming all these things and
took off his jacket a blackjack that he
hadn't thrown on the ground The
Narrative that has emerged has become
about race a white man who fatally
choked a black man the witness said this
isn't about race this is about people of
all colors who are very very afraid and
a man who stepped in to help them so so
here's the picture being painted by the
witnesses they're cowering in the back
of the truck as this guy's screaming
takes his jack off throws it on the
ground
and only at that point when he sang he's
about to kill people or he's going to
and he takes his jacket off
like it looks like he's about to engage
dude these men decide to subdue him they
it it sounds like he had all the things
that or he had exhibited all the things
that necessary for the legitimate
self-defense you know he's there so he's
got his fist he's making threats you
know listen to this the the woman she
said I miss the city under the law and
order of Giuliani when it comes to
exposing people are subjecting them to
Violent Behavior the people who are in
power are supposed to protect us are not
that's that's amazing wow it's
completely correct right these people
they actively work against Civil Society
it's not just the case that you don't
get in trouble for breaking the law you
do get in trouble for stopping somebody
from breaking the law yeah 100 and so
this is what the media has made
perfectly clear to the American people
over the past several years and this is
something they've believed for decades
but they've gotten explicitly clear in
their messaging about this we saw this
during the 2020 riots right 30 people
died the vast majority of people don't
know any of their names but everyone
knows Kyle's Kyle rittenhouse's name do
you know why because he defended himself
he didn't let the mob murder him and
that's not what he was supposed to do he
was supposed to allow himself to be
killed and he didn't which is why he
needs to be charged because he's setting
an example for people he's showing
people that you don't have to roll over
and die because mob is rioting in your
neighborhood or a neighborhood that
you're invested in protecting
there was a there's another name that
everybody remembers do you know what it
is
one other what other person
uh uh David Dorner David Dorney David
Norton yeah you know why they remember
his name he died right he was a police
officer and he was trying to protect a
business that was being looted when they
shot him over a TV and people they
remember his name you're the they I
don't know for For Better or For Worse
if you try and defend yourself people
are gonna remember who you are the left
for bad reasons and the right for good
reasons
do you remember the name of the woman
who was pushed in front of the train and
murdered let me write her name on the
show I can't remember either nope nobody
cares well no one's gonna talk about
that right that's crazy because that's
business as usual but citizens standing
up for themselves against criminals is
not and that's not supposed to happen
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there